vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos de como
schumacher expresiones racionales
supongamos que tenemos menos x cuadrada
entre x cuadrada menos 7 x más 6 y que a
eso le queremos sumar le queremos sumar
x menos 4
entonces de cierta forma lo que quiero
hacer es una cosa del estilo una
división de polinomios larga pero al
revés es decir quiero poner x menos 4 en
el numerador con x cuadrada menos 7 x
más 6 en el denominador y la forma más
fácil de hacer esto es simplemente
multiplicar x menos 4 por un 1 por x
cuadrada menos 7 x + 6 / / x cuadrada
menos 7 x + 6 y no estoy cambiando nada
simplemente estoy multiplicando por un 1
después de hacer este paso seguiremos
desarrollando multiplicando ambos
términos de el numerador y para hacer
esto vamos a utilizar multiplicación
algebraica entonces ponemos x cuadrada
menos 7 x + 6
por x 4
los multiplicamos y entonces seis forman
los cuatro es menos 24 menos 4 x menos 7
x es más 28 x menos 4 por equis
cuadrados menos 4 x cuadrada
x por 666 x x x menos 7 x es menos 7 x
cuadrada y x x x cuadrada es x cúbico
vamos a sumarlo a ver qué pasa esto es x
al cubo menos 11 x cuadrado más 34 x
menos 24 entonces puede reescribir esta
expresión déjame copiar esto a copiar y
pegar blanquista lo ponemos por aquí y
entonces va a ser igual a esto más
y hay que reescribir esta expresión con
la multiplicación que hicimos y entonces
denominador que de x cuadrada menos 7 x
+ 6 y en el numerador pues es justo lo
que hicimos en la multiplicación es este
resultado que es x al cubo menos 11 x
cuadrada más 34 x menos 24
y pues listo ya tenemos estas dos listas
para sumarse porque tienen el mismo
denominador entonces las sumamos
simplemente las sumamos y ya entonces
pues ponemos nuestro denominador común
equis cuadrada menos 7 x más 6 y
entonces para eso hicimos verdad la
multiplicación para que tengamos el
mismo denominador y entonces tenemos que
sumar el numerador entonces después
vamos a ver qué pasa es x al cubo
- 11 x cuadrada hay que restarle el otro
x cuadrado entonces menos 12 x cuadrada
y hay que sumar 34 x menos 24 y ya está
y pues bueno podríamos ver si esto se
puede simplificar desde antes pero al
factorizar esto queda x 6 por x 1 y pues
se entrega pues no tiene nada que ver
con el x menos 4 y entonces vamos a
dejarlo así esperamos que te haya
gustado